Ah ! Bonjour a tous comment allez-vous ? Moi ça va extrêmement mal
Ça va très bien
J'ai simplement une putain de grippe,
mon pote.
Ou devrais-je dire,
j'ai un sacré état grippal !
Mais ça il y a que les médecins qui disent ça !
Et je sors d'un tournage de 30 min,
Euhh...
D'une vidéo qui ne sortira jamais !
*rires*
Parce qu'elle est nulle à chier !
J'ai jamais vu une vidéo où je parlais aussi peu !
C'était peut-être 10 sec de parole,
par minute !
Aujourd'hui, qu'est-ce qu'on va faire du coup ?
Bah j'vais en profiter pour vous parler
Parce que finalement on fait les cons,
on s'amuse sur des jeux lala...
Mais c'est bien aussi de se parler
??? j'voulais vous remercier parce que...
*reniflements*
Désolé !
Déjà j'voulais vous remercier parce que..l'...
Vous avez adoré les dernières vidéos,
vous m'avez envoyés pas mal de,
même des mails et même dans les commentaires
j'ai vu que vous étiez vraiment nombreux à dire que
elles vous plaisaient,
plus que d'habitude !
E t ça se voyait même au niveau des pouces verts
J'avais même fait petit tweet pour vous remercier
C'était assez ouf !
A  pas confondre avec Séoul
Et pas à Séoul
Non c'était en France, c'était pas à Séoul, en Corée
*rires silencieux*
Ah bah on est malade mais...
On est toujours là pour les jeux de mots de merde, hein !
Nan sans déconner, ça m'a fait super chaud
au coeur
Euhh...
Bah d'ailleurs j'ai eu une grippe instantanément
tellement ça m'a fait plaisir !
En fait j'prends beaucoup, beaucoup de plaisir à faire les vidéos,
bien plus qu'avant déjà parce que maintenant
je bosse avec Clément,
qui cadre par exemple les vidéos HTC vive, hein !
On s'amuse beaucoup !
Moi, peut-être plus que lui d'ailleurs !
*rires grippaux*
'tain je m'demande ce qu'il pense quand il filme des fois , Clément !
Voix off de Clément - ohh putain, qu'est-ce que j'suis entraint de faire de ma vie...
C'est un peu triste d'être tout le temps seul,
dans ce qu'on aime faire !
D'ailleurs c'est pour ça que maintenant j'ai un studio
Comme vous avez pu le voir !
Et non je ne fais plus les vidéos de chez moi !
Et pourquoi ça ?
Parce qu'en fait je pétais un câble à rester chez moi,
toute la jounée !
Et quand j'bossais,
et quand j'bossais pas,
et quand je jouait !
J'était tout le temps entre les mêmes murs !
Et ça ma rendu fou !
Alors qu'la le fait d'me lever le matin comme tout l'monde,
à 11h !
Ah youtubeur c'est chômeur !
Et j'vois pas du tout ça comme un truc désagréable,
au contraire,
c'est super cool de s'lever, de bouger de chez soi
mais d'aller dans un endroit qu'on aime tout autant que chez soi !
Pour y faire un truc qu'on aime !
'fin bref, c'est super, je suis, vraiment aux anges depuis que j'ai ce petit studio
Enfin petit, il est quand même grand,
j'ai de la chance !
Voilà du coup je disais quoi ?
Ah oui : pourquoi vous trouviez les vidéos meilleures qu'avant ?
Et ouais quand on est youtubeur, on prend du plaisir à faire les vidéos,
bah ça se voit !
Et quand il en prend moins, ça se voit aussi !
Et ça m'arrivera surement d'en prendre moins dans certaines vidéos que dans d'autres
bien évidemment !
Et deuxième truc c'est les putains de commentaires :
oh la la depuis qu'il y a l'équipe de modération là qui est au taquet,
c'est fantastique !
J'prends trop de plaisir à lire les commentaires,
j'ai vraiment l'impression de faire des vidéos,
et que des gens les regardent et pas de les faire dans le vent !
Enfait, même si il y a marqué "1 ou 2 millions de vues",
c'est énorme !
C'est astronomique comme chiffre !
C'est incroyable mais tu te rends pas vraiment compte
alors que quand c'est des gens qui t'écrivent des choses,
tu te rends plus compte !
Et du coup depuis que je relis plus les commentaires,
et que je vois vos phrases, vos trucs marrants, vos délires, vos infos,
ça m'fait vraiment plaisir !
Voilà je vous remercie pour cet espace commentaire qui est redevenu
génial !
Je remercie les gens qui postent des commentaires vraiment cools
Je remercie l'équipe de modération,
et je remercie ceux qui m'avaient prévenus de l'existence
de ce système de modération de commentaires youtubes,
parce que...
Putain j'en ai pas la moindre idée !!
Hier on s'est chié dessus sur un jeu d'horreur,
aujourd'hui, on se remercie,
c'est super beau...
Ça n'a aucun sens ce que je viens de dire, on s'en bat les couilles !
Et deuxième chose, j'avais ouvert ma boutique de t-shirts il y a à peu près 1 an je crois
et j'en est jamais reparlé depuis.
Et vous savez quoi ?
Ya des nouveautés !!!
Comme par exemple ce putain de pull,
que j'kiffe trop porter !
C'était une super vanne !
Une super Van's !
*craquements d'os*
Nan j'avoue j'ai déconné, j'suis le mec le moins vendeur au monde,
j'ai oublié d’amener, euhhh...
Les t-shirts et les pulls, pour vous montrer
*rires*
Bon du coup j'vous met des petites photos par-ci, par-là !
Ya notamment le (Pullstic?) man que je trouve vraiment cool !
Il est aussi cool que le style que j'ai actuellement !
Achetez-le, hein !
C'est trop kiffant d'pouvoir proposer des vêtements, comme ça,
vous êtes pas du tout obligés d'les acheter, d'ailleurs
si vous aimez pas, achetez absolument pas !
Mais ça me fait plaisir de proposer ça à ceux qui ont envie que ça existe !
Et d'leur proposer des trucs un peu cools, un peu marrant, un peu..
Bon ya forcément le t-shirt basique avec marqué Squeezie dessus, hein !
Mais y'a des trucs un peu plus cools que même moi je met dans la vie de tout les jours
alors que mettre un t-shirt avec marqué Squeezie dessus,
certains osent pas et je comprends tout à fait !
Enfin bon voilà n'hésitez pas à faire un tour dans la boutique
si vous voulez, en plus c'est Noël et tout là,
Y'a d'la tune, hein ! Là les gens ont d'la tunes !
Et sinon vous allez au Zara en bas de chez vous et c'est bien aussi !
Et bien voilà c'est déjà la fin d'cette petite vidéo de type grippal !
J'espère qu'elle vous a plu !
Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas à aller à la pharamacie !
Mon gars j'ai acheté la panoplie :
J'ai mis les gouttes pour le nez,
le spray pour la gorge,
le Doliprane,
le sirop pour la toux sèche,
le sirop pour la toux grasse,
le sirop contre la toux rista !
Turista !
OOOOHHHHH !!!
*craquements d'os*
J'suis désolé de vous importuner avec ses blaques nulles,
mais vous me pardonnez, parce que là je suis en souffrance !
Eh ben j'crois que c'est tout ce que j'avais à dire...
Ah oui y'a un petit let's play qui arrivera dans 2 semaines,
1e épisode qui sortira le 5 décembre, j'espère que ça vous plaira,
on va faire une ambiance tamisée, posée, comme on avait fait
pour Inside !
Ah je tease !
Ouais j'fais un vrai teaser, ouais !
Ah bah nan on part sur un gros buzz, hein !
Encore plus que le trailer de Ghost In The Shell !
*musique du trailer*
Le 5 décembre,
il revient pour un nouveau let's play !
C'est tout pour les news,
c'était la petite vidéo ambiance tamisée, posée maladie !
Désolée de pas avoir fait une vidéo un peu plus marrante,
mais là j'avoue, j'arrive plus à réfléchir !
C'est chaud !
J'ai carrément du faire un mémo,
pour retenir ce que j'avais à vous dire !
J'écris comme un CE1, ouais !
Merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo
et merci de regarder toutes les vidéos en général !
Vous êtes vraiment géniaux !
Donc je vous dis à très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo !
Je vous remercie une nouvelle fois :
merci, merci, merci, merci !
Portez-vous bien,
couvrez-vous bien, histoire d'avoir pas d'état grippal, hein !
Venez on banni le mot "grippe" de la langue française !
On dit que état grippal maintenant !
Allez à très vite, portez-vous bien, tchao tout le monde...
PPEEAACCEE !!!
Allez faut dormir !
- Sous-titres réalisés par une anonyme sous état grippal, ne faisant rien de sa journée #EtatGrippal -